j'ai commencé le karaté il ya six mois
et depuis je suis adepte à pro le karaté
diop pense que ça a beaucoup vu ça m'a
apporté beaucoup de force beaucoup de
sérénité où c'est vraiment quelque chose
que je recommande à beaucoup beaucoup
personnes ont passé toutes mes ceintures
de façon à ventre est en compétition
dans pas très longtemps
c'est quelque chose qui me plaît
vraiment et j'ai vraiment envie de faire
de la compétition parce que c'est la
compétitivité c'est la combativité le
karaté doit entraîner cette affaire a
mené aussi certaine combativité une
certaine envie de compétitivité de de
montrer ce qu'on sait faire d'eux de se
battre en fait voilà est de savoir quel
niveau on est dans lé sud du quartier
qu'on a appris
c'est une discipline qui demande
beaucoup de respect de soi de l'autre du
tatami
des partenaires qui demande beaucoup de
maîtrise et on ne peut pas pratiquer
juste comme ça pour agresser quelqu'un
un peu mais seulement sa défense en
maîtrisant les techniques et en
diffusant une bonne puissance on va dire